pour la première fois on voit la
persécution et la répression brutale de
la minorité musulmane ouïghoure de
l'intérieur même du système étatique
secrets chinois des milliers de
portraits de femmes d'hommes et même
d'adolescents de 15 ans prix après leur
arrestation des photos des exercices
anti émeute dans les camps d'internement
au cours desquelles on donne
l'instruction au gardien de tirer pour
tuer s'il ya tentative d'évasion
ce qu'on appelle les sindian police
files ces milliers de documents piratés
dans les serveurs de la police chinoise
et publié par un consortium de 14 médias
c'est le chercheur et d'huile zen ce qui
les a obtenu 95
[Musique]
les documents et transcriptions de
conversations démontre même que le
président chinois xi jingping est
personnellement impliqué dans le système
répressif c'est justement cet amas de
preuves
d'instruction et d'une volonté justement
de nuire à la population ouïghoure qui
démontre qu'on devait vraiment
s'inquiéter et qu'on est fier et vidic a
ici affaire probablement un génocide
les révélations sur la répression des
ouigours sont publiées au moment où la
haute commissaire des nations unies aux
droits de l'homme mme michelle bachelet
entame une visite dans le xinjiang
une tournée encadré sous haute
surveillance dans une bulle sanitaire
antico vide et dans des lieux précis
prédéterminé aucun journaliste ni a
accès il n'y aura aucun commentaire
après la visite son pareil
le gouvernement chinois qualifie les
indians police phase de rumeurs et de
mensonges
l'oeuvre des etats-unis de la
grande-bretagne et d'autres pays
occidentaux visant à saboter la visite
de michelle bachelet
bon nombre de défenseurs des droits de
la personne craignent plutôt que sa
visite servent à la propagande chinoise
il était de démontrer que physiquement
ces visites n'amènera aucune vérité est
ce qu'il faut regarder c'est justement
ces nouveaux documents qu'elles ont
accès aujourd'hui
les révélations sur le thin zhang
suscite de nouveau appel aux sanctions
contre les hauts dirigeants du parti
communiste chinois il si philippe
leblanc radio canada toronto